les vendanges commencent généralement en
automne mais cette année elles se sont
terminées en été pour la famille cadart
pour les viticulteurs pas de doute le
changement climatique à de fortes
conséquences sur la vigne on a été
impacté par la sécheresse par le manque
d'eau de l'hiver dernier ça a continué
au printemps et cet été et on estime à
peu près 30% la perte de récolte sur
l'année 2019 avec le gel la sécheresse
est devenu l'ennemi numéro un du
vigneron
seuls 20 millimètres de pluie sont
tombées cet été du côté de chenonceau
résultat la récolte s'annonce très
mauvaise 20 hectolitres par hectare pas
suffisant pour être rentable alors la
question c'est comment irriguer les
vignes une question nouvelle
comme nous sommes installés les grands
parents une mode multi gabon centralise
il y aura des années de gel des terres
et de grêle des années où il pleuvra
beaucoup mais au moins il fallait
ajouter une chose de sûre c'est que la
vie ne craint pas la sécheresse
aujourd'hui m'inscris en faux homo
précédemment cité ben la sécheresse mais
alors quelles sont les solutions la
réflexion est en cours le domaine
château de 15 c est l'un des trois sites
pilotes choisies par la région pour
rétablir un scénario d'adaptation des
idées émergent déjà pendant les
canicules par exemple travailler de nuit
ou travailler très tôt le matin ça va
être pendant les vendanges travailler
aussi la nuit pour récolter un réseau
assez froid pour garder toute la qualité
de la vendange
donc il ya plein de choses à mettre en
place pour pour lutter contre ce
changement climatique et on se pose
encore beaucoup de questions au dessus
et ses réflexions serviront notamment au
lycée viticole de la région
la question du changement climatique et
progressivement intégrées au programme